well that's
over two years every single week
i've been interviewing winner after
winner after the winner and they all
started
at this property investors crash course
and i have so many
winners on wednesdays and have them for
the last two
years and i've got winners on wednesdays
booked up until
october this year and there's no other
training company
on the planet that is doing what we are
doing here
and you can look at all the different
property courses and what they'll do is
they'll say oh you're a nice boy you're
a nice skill they'll tap you and they'll
give you little bits and bobs
and then they'll sell you on a course
and then i'll send you another course
and then they'll send them another
thoughts
do we have an advanced training program
attractive i can't give more training
courses for free
i give a lot for it and some of it is
painful we need to understand how to
work out the return on investment
that's the birth and we need to know
what return on investment or good or bad
looks like
because if you're going to buy
properties you need to know what the
property looks like
and if you're going to package and sell
properties and sell them to investment
you definitely need to know what it
looks like
so let's work out what averages average
average average the average
[Music]
remember the formulas and both of them
like me i was terrible but
there's a couple of formulas that you
just
need to know and if you're looking at
math it's needed about formulas and
stuff
man i'm just a people person you need to
know these formulas
and it's very simple and you can use a
calculator
so you just need the formulas you can
use a calculator but some people got
little blocks
deposit now how do you work out what a
25 percent deposit
[Applause]
about is rounds you need to formulate so
you just do this
really simple i know some people aren't
teaching you to suck x but you just need
to get
so you go 200 thousands so you can see
okay
it's about 2 000 times
twenty-five percent which is zero plus
five
equals fifty thousand that is the figure
so twenty-one percent that is the
deposit so the deposit
is fifty thousand however
fifty thousand do we just need to
deposit or do we need another cost
and what's in the box legally due to
our legal fees and staff duty will vary
however to keep things really simple for
the purpose of the crash course that
says four percent
now when in real life you're actually
going to buy a house you might go oh
he's actually
three percent or five percent or
whatever you might respond but you know
four percent because that's about
standard is that okay yes or no
yes you can just do 29
but it's important that you understand
what the actual deposit is so 29
of 200 000 is fifty eight thousand
pounds
and fifty eight thousand pounds if you
were buying
if you were buying a two hundred
thousand pound house
you would need about fifty eight
thousand pounds
savings to buy the house now could you
just go and get a loan out or whatever
but maybe but let's just
right now we're walking out there our
wife will return
thank you so 58 000 pounds now the
formula
to work out the return on investment is
simple the formula
is this is where you take the annual
profit
the annual profit and you divide that
by the total investment
and the absolute you get you then times
the answer by 100
and that will equal your return on
investment
so the annual profit of a standard
average we're going to work out in a
minute
you take the annual profit divided by
the total investment what's the total
investment
58 grams because the total investment
is 29 of the thing that you're buying
and then your times are thinking 100 so
let's do this so if you're buying a 200
house what would be
the likely rent on a 200 000 pounds
house because you rent a little house
right 50 or
70 taxes that you bought for 200. you
could
the house isn't real it's just to work
out so if it's 800 pounds a month what's
that per year
so the rent is
two hundred pounds is that money
yours yeah
but the house has got a mortgage on it
so you have to pay the mortgage yes or
no guys
you are are you gonna have to pay for
maintenance on the house yes are you
gonna
pay for mortgages um management fees and
stuff
yeah but that 10 200 you can't say oh
well i'm just going to spend that money
because that would be irresponsible so
it's not
[Music]
[Applause]
you